Good morning, folks.
We're back live.
Hello.
and get a good like 12 hours of
streaming in.
I have some big plans for this. Um,
I want to really really finish up
our logging correctly. I don't want to
have to change our logging again after
today before release.
It's worth spending a couple hours on
that if I need to do it uh in order to
make sure it's completely stable.
We will launch some sweeps.
I'm not sure which ones I want to do
first. If I want to do like a couple of
the small ones first, we'll see.
Um, but we're going to launch some
sweeps.
We're going to spend some time looking
at the Cudasaurus.
Uh, if that is going slow, I will move
back to constellation. But I think we
can spend some time on the cuda source.
Those are the main main things today.
I'm going to throw these on.
Oh, and also,
let me just uh
I figure I may as well throw this on my
side monitor.
I've had that up the last uh couple
weeks just like AFKing a silly account.
I don't know.
So, okay. Um
in the meantime here, uh things I need
to figure out for today. The main thing
I'm not sure about is how I want to log
It's essentially it has to do with the
trajectories, right? Like I know how to
log the final points easily enough.
Sure,
I can get that done stably,
but what I'd like to be able to do is
I'd like to be able to log down sample
points uh for each of these. And that's
a little bit harder. I believe it's a
little bit harder.
I think it's going to need some sort of
robustness method. Hey, Jess. Hey,
Mystic. Yeah, I went to bed early, Jess.
I got uh I got a whole bunch of stuff
done.
Well, not done. I got like a whole bunch
of non puffer stuff done, let's say.
Um,
I had a little personal project I was
working on.
Okay,
get started.
This on
the chat where I can see it. Good.
Okay.
Yeah. So this thing here, no bueno,
right?
What I was thinking of doing here.
What needs logs?
What if I do this? Matrix equals down
sample.
Thought I'd check out what we're working
on.
Currently, we're trying to fix up the
logging for Puffer Core.
Um here we don't need claude.
I don't need any claude here.
All right. So this is constellation
and we have all these nice metrics here.
And I'm trying to think how I want to
log data to get into this format. And
I'm sick of changing the format because
I have to rerun all these experiments.
Every single point is an experiment
here. I have to keep rerunning
experiments every time I change the
format. So I want to actually just spend
some time this morning to think about
it, clean up the code and get something
we can use
review so I absolutely want that Tim
like let me be clear that is going to be
a top five environment. Uh I'm pretty
sure that will be a top five environment
for research in Puffer.
Do you have the code cleaned up already?
Like
I haven't been that excited about an
environment PR in a while, Tim. Just
because that's really really really
going to be a good end for research
I'm trying to I think if I want to do
H
I'm pretty amateur. Let me take a quick
peek at it. See if I have any guidance
for you and then uh I'll set some time
aside to do a full review. All right.
Cuz I I am behind on Puffer 4. I had a
um
I mean I may as well tell you I uh I had
this personal project over the last
couple of days. The personal project was
my dumb ass finally getting my license.
So, I got my license in like literally
three days. Probably should not show
that on stream, but I got one.
Yay.
Now I cannot deal with that anymore.
I literally just never bothered to get
it.
Why would it be a good end for research?
It's kind of like Maze Jazz. It's a pure
exploration task.
It's got a little bit of It's a little
different though than uh Maz's
puffer learning speed. It would have
been one day tail. So, it literally
would have been one day. I failed it the
first time because it didn't say
anywhere on the website that they don't
let you use your cameras to park. So,
you know, I learned to park with the
cameras and uh then they said, "Oh, you
have to turn those off." So, I just
barely hit one of the freaking cones
parking
because they box you in completely like
So, I took another couple days to like
relearn without the cameras and then uh
yeah, it would have literally been one
day.
All right, 17 files changed to sketch.
Let's see why there are 17 files
changed. Oh, okay. This is fine.
Uh we're going to need different uh
we're going to need different license on
this Tim.
Uh like we're going to need different
assets that aren't licensed like this.
I uh I can't keep um I can't PR anything
that has a copy left license.
It's just the assets presumably, right?
If you see a pack online, even if it's
like I can purchase a license for the
project, I'll just buy it for you for
the project, but I can't incorporate a
um so the problem with this, right, is
that this this gets legally sketchy and
then any companies using Puffer, like
even if it's just the the assets for
this, you just don't want to have
anything that has this license on it in
an open source codebase.
I mean, there are lots and lots of free
asset packs that are not licensed like
this.
Yeah, you can't do this.
It doesn't need to go here, but that's
fine.
Why do you have a custom SegV handler?
Are you developing on a Mac or
something?
shouldn't need any of this.
Your debugging for seg should just be
covered by um
if you just compile with local mode,
it'll enable address sanitizer for you.
I don't remember how we do paths for our
map, so I'll have to test this. But this
is fine for local for sure.
And the lot of this will be on YouTube
as well if you need. I may as well just
go through now if it's not a huge amount
of coke. We'll see.
You can have both ships if you want.
It's fine.
Why don't you Why
GPL
Dude, GPL's copy left
the [ __ ]
Literally any contract that you sign
with a big company, the first thing that
they do is no goddamn copy left licenses
anywhere anywhere. Get out out. Like
MIT license is do what the [ __ ] you want
with the code. That is the actual open
source license.
Like Puffer Lib is not nonprofit, right?
It's open source, but I'm allowed to
commercialize stuff. And the way that we
do that is by uh we build custom SIMs
for companies. We do dedicated R&D. You
know,
you can't completely hamstring my
ability to uh make any money in the
process of doing this.
Oh, why MIT? Yeah, MIT is like do what
the [ __ ] you want with it pretty much.
It's probably the best known license.
There are a couple of them like Apache
or whatever. Like there a couple that
are fine, but um MIT is just the most
widely known.
It's like a one paragraph license. It's
very easy.
Yeah, like this is duped. This could be
an allocate. Like this could be a a
function because you're duping this.
This is bad to dupe because if you
change the obace size. Oh, no. You
actually It's not that bad because you
have it like this. Not that bad.
Okay. Uh that's fine.
Okay, ignore this like nesting but this
right here.
Wait, what the heck? No, ignore that.
I believe it's this.
It looks It's It's either this or very
close to it.
Um, so yeah, Tim, learn this.
what you do is you put all these things
in this and then you do, you know,
that's fine.
And then the binding we'll check this
difficulty full.
Your way looked better.
What do you mean? Your way looks better.
Oh, it might have eaten one of your
messages.
me. This is going to be a bit of a pain
to port to see. What is this?
Collect maps.
Oh, you did put it in the download.
That's why it's Okay, that's fine.
I'll figure this out for you because I'm
going to have to port this to see.
Um,
Now, let's check the last one, which is
the environment.
Oh, wait. No, there's the map gem.
Map gems in Python.
I'm going to end up just porting the
whole map gen to uh to see most likely
Tim
M. Yeah. Yeah. I have I do the exact
same thing with several M and Puffer.
That's fine.
I'll end up porting the gem to C, but no
big deal.
GPT and all sorts. You could literally
just check the mobile end cuz we do the
same thing there. You don't have to m
map it though, dude. Like
it's literally just shared me.
You can do it at a process level. So you
have one copy per worker instead of per
N.
Okay, let's go look at the actual code
because this is all imported.
base. This probably doesn't need to be
global. I don't know what this is.
Yeah, these don't need to get set
extern.
Yeah, this is so this is you not knowing
how we do our shared stuff.
I stop here. Let's just do let me go
with this browser.
the thing is there's not that much point
in me showing you this because it like
it changes a fair bit in um in Puffer 4.
Does it? Yes.
Yeah. So, here look this is how I did it
in Puffer 4. I read the file. I make the
memory for it.
return the state
and then the state gets used in here.
Um, but then this year it only gets
called once per process instead of once
per end.
It's pretty similar in 4.0.
here.
Pretty similar
with the shared files. You have to make
end changes. The shared stuff is going
to have to be changed. The end of itself
is going to have almost no changes
required
because you have shared stuff. There
will be have to be some changes to that.
You got a bunch of weird stuff imported
as well.
I'll look at this stuff, but bunch of
weird like shared logic.
Yeah, you don't need to map it. Okay,
this is um
they are loaded from file I suppose
but they don't need to be admapped. They
can just get loaded and then shared.
Yeah, drive is good in 300. Moa is also
simple.
I hate macros like this, dude. I I hate
macros like this. Just make functions.
Inline functions. Don't do Don't make
macros like this.
This just [ __ ] with your debugging is
all it does.
Because what this does is this does like
a flat text replace.
It just replaces this with the text
and that just breaks a whole bunch of
debugging.
I tried and I only really use pound
defines for constants when I can avoid
it
What am I doing? Quick code review for
Tim Socabon PR and then back to working
on our uh logging logic for puffer port.
Oh, hang on. I think I see what you did.
Square target of your template.
Uh, there's literally an environment
called template. Roger. If you want like
a really minimal one to play around
with, if you're making a multi- aent
end, I think target is a better starting
point. For single agent ends, you can
literally copy the template end.
I don't know why this is like brown now.
I don't know what I clicked.
I'll get to your computer ops thing.
So, wait. It's end. You did end of
observations.
What intermediate rewards do you have?
Kind of weird.
Hey, Rain Jen, welcome.
So, I don't know what this is. whether
this is easier to just check this. Um
See, you have some stuff here that I
thought, oh, he does this for
efficiency. And then you do this, which
is incredibly inefficient. So, I'm
confused.
you just straight up shouldn't need any
double for loops over the um the end,
man.
Let me see.
All these things here
you you're you're calcing them at the
wrong time.
You should be doing this calc when you
move the agent. That's when you should
be calcing this stuff because nothing
changes except when you move the agent.
So what you're doing is you're moving
the agent and then you're like, "Ah,
shoot. I didn't check the information.
Then I got to go run double for loops
for everything.
Let me finish looking. Hang on.
This is all of it. Yeah. Okay. Pause my
music. Okay. So So
Tim, the good thing that you've done
here
All right. The good thing that you've
done here is you've only kept one
representation of data and you've kept
it all nicely in contiguous memory. Now
I'm going to explain. Okay. So the good
thing you've done here is you have one
representation of the end and you've
kept it in observations because you
noticed that the state of the
environment is the same as the
observation data. This is the very this
is very good. Okay. Uh the thing that
you've completely missed,
the thing you've completely missed is
like how to actually use that state
efficiently.
So this is our maze environment. It's
pretty similar. This is a nice reference
for you. Uh note that this is a little
bit over complicated because I was doing
stuff with keys and doors in here that's
not super relevant anymore.
But
let's see. Okay, we have strct grid.
Okay, this one I suppose is a little bit
different because our obs are separate
in this one cuz it's local observations
which to be fair I don't know if you
want local observations or global obs
and so
you might end up wanting the local obs.
This one you just observe a crop of the
tiles around you with the maze here.
So this is how I compute I compute
observations for the maze. Right?
Zero it and then this is the only for
loop. Right? This is the only for loop
that I have a double for loop in the uh
in the environment.
And then the thing that I wanted to show
you.
Yeah. So like look to move the agent.
Okay. We get the address. We get the
destination. We check if it's a wall. We
don't move into walls. Right? We check
if it's a goal or a reward. We give it
the goal or the reward. Right? Do our
logging. We check if it's a key. We do
the key stuff. We check for doors. We do
the door stuff. So when we move, we do
all the logic
because the thing is you're not doing
this. So you end up with all these
double for loops like ah shoot. I moved
but I didn't actually do it. Did it I
didn't do it when I moved. So now I have
to check
after the fact.
I think also for OBS, it's fine to have
um a little function like this grid
offset or whatever. It's fine to have a
little function to get the address so
you don't screw up this little one line.
It should be inlined actually. Don't
make it a macro.
I think that's the main thing that you
that you messed up. Let me see if I can
find
Let me go find back to your PR.
Okay, that's not bad. Actually, if you
just need to do this once on uh reset,
that's fine.
See agent pause. You should just store
this in the end,
right? You should just have like X Y for
the agent.
Just do it all in one.
No. No. It's not like you need to you
don't need to unroll your double for
loops. That's not what I'm saying. I'm
saying that you have the code structured
like you shouldn't need to loop at all
like this. You shouldn't have to do this
at all because the end should just have
agent X agent Y and it should update it
when you move it. Then you never need to
call this thing that has double for
loops because it'll just be N of X and
Y. Wait, you do have N agent X.
Oh, is this called on net?
Hang
on. If this is just called on a net,
then it's fine. Oh, it is called on a
net.
Well, then you can at least merge these
two, man. You don't these don't need to
be separate functions if they're called
once. You can literally just put your
two for loops in here and then do them
both in one pass.
Yeah. So, these can both just be done on
one pass.
Okay, maybe this is not as bad as I
thought you are. I didn't realize that
you were just using See, I thought
because you had these functions that you
were going to be using them everywhere
because the re Why would I think that,
right, Tim? It would never occur to me
to split out this function that's only
getting used once. And lo and behold,
right, you actually looped twice because
you decided to split out functions. If
you didn't split these out, it would
have been immediately obvious to you
that you could just do both of these in
one pass. Like uh you could do them both
at the same time and it would just be at
the bottom of C reset. Not everything
has to be split out into a function. In
general, I like that your cue to split
something out into a function should be
you having to call it multiple times.
Don't just split stuff out into
functions for the sake of it because you
miss stuff like that.
Okay, but this is not as bad as I
thought. Then um now this get
intermediate rewards. Let's see. Get
where's this called?
No wait. This is called once but it's
called every step.
Care for clean quality code is required.
Roger. Especially in RL, bugs in RL are
like 10 times worse.
You don't get an error. You get the
thing doesn't learn correctly and you
don't know why.
Actually, I made a post on this the
other day.
If I need to refactor your code this
way, then you have not built it
correctly. Let me show you.
So when I get a messy code base, I
literally will just delete everything
that's only called once and inline it.
And then I will look at the code when
it's not redundant and I will see if
stuff needs to be split up.
The problem is if you start splitting
stuff up too early in your code, you
miss stuff like this and you make stuff
more obscure, right? Because now I'm
reading through your code and I'm
thinking like, oh, get intermediate. So
what? Like I see, look, I see you
looping through the entire M state a
bunch of times and I have to actually go
jump to where this is called in order to
see like why on earth you have all these
loops only to see that they're done
once.
Something so fundamental for stuff you
just punch. They tell you the opposite.
Roger is the problem. So, um, computer
science is an absolutely terribly taught
discipline. They will tell you to just
split stuff up as soon as you get to 25
lines or something. I have no idea why.
Like, programming education is so bad
that it virtually guarantees you will be
an absolutely awful programmer for the
first 5 to 10 years of programming
because you have to unlearn all the
garbage they tell you.
It's so sad, too, because like good
programming in my mind, it's the closest
thing you get to clear thinking. Like,
it's the closest thing you get to the
expression of just pure, simple, clean
logic in its most elementary form. Um,
math is too abstract and you don't have
a compiler that actually checks it and
checks your [ __ ] You have to get
another person to go do that. Um, so
programming is really really great in my
mind, but it's not great in the form
that it's taught. The form that it's
taught just kind of makes it seem like
this blleh fuzzy mess, not like
something that's very clear and simple,
which is what it should be.
I got a coefficient to turn it on and
off. Well, see, because of the way you
have it structured, I don't actually
know whether this is needed yet. And I
have to do more work to like read
through your code and figure out whether
this is actually needed.
ever do industry work? Yeah, the problem
is most industry programmers suck as
well.
It's really only the people that have
taken the time to just like really try
to get better at programming over time
and then realized through me over many
projects like, oh wait, it's way better
if I just do it this way.
The reason for this, Tim, is because you
can technically push stuff off the
boxes, right? Like, you can technically
push the boxes off.
They don't lock in place, right? Once
they're on the target tile.
Okay.
Why do you need the number?
What's this?
Did me did Betton Spencer have messy
code as well during their first NPR?
Spencer sent me one of the worst damn
NPRs I've ever seen on his first N and
um is now absolutely kicking ass. Like I
would take him over your typical MIT
grad and RL
easily.
Actually, do we still have it?
I remember it being even worse than
this. Should we clean this up?
Oh, there it is.
Look at this.
like you just make a helper function to
do the pointer arithmetic once and then
you never mess it up.
You make like a oneliner.
Okay. Um I don't understand this.
Tim, can you explain this
on RL or reasoning problems?
Wait, what do you mean on reasoning
problems?
Are both of these in the context of
language models?
Can you even do that as a PhD student?
You don't have compute for that [ __ ] do
you?
No general reasoning.
What does that mean?
Because like that's not a like that's
not a well- definfined problem.
You find if any new boxes are on targets
and you get reward times coefficient.
Wait,
solving the RKGI problem. Yeah, but
that's a language model task, dude.
Like that's meant for human pattern
recognition. That's not reasoning.
That's human visual priors.
You can't solve that problem from first
principles.
Okay, Tim, your reward structure is
wrong. This is why it's over
complicated. This is not how you do
reward structures.
you've just over complicated it. So what
you do with this, don't give it a reward
in proportion to the number of good
things it's done. Give it a reward when
it does the good thing once.
Yeah, don't do that. Just give it plus
one whenever it moves a box onto a
target. You see?
So when it moves the box onto the
target, the first time it moves a box
onto the target, know each target
plus one.
That means it'll never have a reward
greater than one total. It'll either
have zero or one on every step.
It depends on how much compute you have,
man.
I think that working with the big models
like working with large in large model
regime when you don't have compute is
just generally not a lot of fun. But
then again, I can't exactly advise RL
stuff um because the academia RL is so
messed up at the moment. Like I left and
I've made so much more progress in the
two years since I've left. Like RL is a
completely different field now with
Puffer whether or not academia has
realized it. Like we're doing stuff that
was impossible two years ago.
Scared of the job market situ. It also
depends on your university,
right? Like how much you have to hedge
your direction depends on where you're
coming from. It depends on a lot.
Like in my case, right, I can go I could
just be anywhere I want within two
months.
Like I have good enough low-level
skills. I'm good enough general
programming. I have a strong strong
enough um general ML background. I can
work on any sub area of ML I want other
than like hard theory uh within two
months.
Does it have to be smaller that for one
box than win?
Well, Tim, you win when you put all the
boxes on the targets, right?
You Yes. Keep it as a coefficient that
you can turn off. Sure.
But it's not gameable, right? Because
the maximum reward is for putting all
the boxes on all the targets.
So, I would just give it like plus one
for every time it puts a box. And then
you don't need to do any of this
counting, right? Because whenever it
moves, if it puts the box on the target,
you zero out that reward and give it to
do with. That's it.
I know Keanu if you've seen um if you've
seen some of my work in RL like if you
look at my um my thesis defenses online
that thesis was so much work for what
would be considered now a relatively
simple environment
well by puffer standards not by anybody
else's standards. um
cuz it ran like a few thousand steps per
second.
I basically had to go re-engineer the
field to be fast.
And then the the problem is that the
things that are required in RL
are not always the thing that academia
appreciates. So I'm not even really
thinking about oh the job market or
whatever, right? Because in my mind um
like low-level MLG
uh practical experiments work,
architectures work with you can just do
work wherever you want very quick, very
easily. It's mostly the fighting
academia on pubs thing that's annoying.
I've written a fair bit about this. if
you read through some of my articles.
But then the language model stuff is
just so bloated and ridiculous that like
realistically
if you don't have a ton of compute and
you're not very well set up for it,
you're kind of just not going to end up
doing anything useful because the labs
are just way better resource for this
stuff than you are and they're actively
doing it and there's really not that
much room for being clever.
Iceberg video is good. Um, I've made a
lot of progress since then. We now have
Puffer running over 10 million steps per
second on a single GPU.
Yeah. So, Tim, this is the major thing
on your reward cos.
This goal is good. You set terms. Do
clear terms. You do clear terms. Good.
You avoid all the main bugs.
Don't do this,
Tim. Don't do this.
This is gamma.
Yeah, Tim, gamma does this for you. The
gamma parameter of generalized advantage
estimation already does this implicitly.
All that this does is this biases your
optimal solution.
So, if you set this too high, it'll
decide to just like Well, I guess it
depends. There's no failure condition, I
suppose.
It's still not great.
Yeah, just delete this. Don't Don't do
this in general. Like, get this is the
job of gamma. Exactly. So, this is just
an algorithmic misunderstanding. Don't
do this.
Okay. So, I mean, I've given you your
stuff to fix. It wasn't as bad as I
thought on the first uh on the first go
through. I thought it was bad though
because you split all this stuff out for
functions you're only using once. So
obviously if I see something that's
split out that's only used once, I think
that you're using it in a bunch of
places. So I think you're calling for
loops everywhere.
Oh yeah, like boxes on targets before.
Look, you are doing it here. You
literally you are. Wait, no, no, no, no.
I missed this. You are doing it here.
Look, you're going through twice. What
is this, right?
Okay, this is actually now this is where
you have to think about this. Look,
double for loop through the environment.
Take an action. You know immediately
whether you've put a box on the target,
right? You can just count the number of
boxes on targets plus one, minus one, or
zero. All right, you don't have to for
loop. You don't need any for loops over
the environment. This gets deleted, this
gets deleted. You get like plus two
lines of code and take action.
You see Tim
get intermediate rewards. This also
doesn't need a double for loop. This
also just gets computed and take action
purely for logging.
int boxes on targets, right? Plus one
when you move the box onto the target,
minus one if you move it off the target.
You don't need to double for loop.
The only for loops I see here that are
justified are um potentially scanning
the map at the start. Oh, and because
the maps are are static, by the way, if
you wanted to, you could literally
premputee that,
you could literally premputee the number
of boxes and stuff just in the maps and
then you would need zero double for
loops. You'd have no double for loops
anywhere
and would run way faster. It'd be a
super nice test environment. You could
run this thing 10 million on one
singular CPU core and we would have an
amazing time with it.
You see
Yeah. When you load the map, loading the
map could just be the me copy plus
setting the num targets and initial
position and stuff. Actually, I think I
do that in mazes.
You get the agent position.
This is static, right? And you get count
boxes.
Okay, you literally already know the
agent position in the map, right? It
doesn't change.
I guess it's slightly annoying because
you'd have to store it in this flat
memory. I'd probably make it structured
to make it a little less errorprone. But
like one dumb way to do it would just be
like when you compute the map, you know,
you store num boxes
uh x y
And then the map,
right?
Map changes each reset. Yes. But the
maps themselves are static.
So each map when you make the maps,
right, you can premp compute the number
of boxes in that map and the starting
position.
You don't change your starting position
when you play the same map multiple
times, right? you reset to a different
map that has a single starting point and
number of boxes.
Yeah, literally everything's
precomputable. You need zero for loops
in this or zero double for loops for
over the map.
You can make this thing super fast.
You can actually make the code shorter
by doing this.
This will be very instructive. Actually,
this is a very good task for you. Yeah,
just add two integers, three integers
because you also get the back the box
count or whatever.
I think this will be very informative
for you, Tim. I think you'll become a
much better programmer just by doing
this.
like that you'll just you'll basically
you'll just see how much simpler
everything becomes and how much clearer
you think about the problem when you do
it this way
of course hey I say I will review M like
I I may sometimes get behind in my
reviews but I review M when people PR me
useful stuff um all I ask is that you
actually you know finish it and fix it
up so we get this PR because actually
this is going to be a super useful item
I don't know how I didn't think of this
before but this will be a very very nice
end but it has to be done correctly.
Code has to be simple and you know high
confidence and it'll be good.
Yeah, Spencer I was showing him your
triple triad before with the freaking
double and triple triple pointers
everywhere.
It's better I be an [ __ ] in the
review and just tell you all the things.
so that you actually fix them and learn
from it. I figure.
Yeah. No, of course, Tim. Thank you.
Cool.
Oh, yeah. Hey, Spence. This is latest
constellation. We're fixing up the log
format stuff today so I can stop
changing the format and breaking all of
our experiments. But, um, you know,
boom, boom.
Sort by hidden size
copies to clipboard instantly
whenever you click it.
There you go. Constellation.
Any C skills? The cool thing about C is
there's literally it's five things you
need to know pretty much. You need to
know what a pointer is. You need to know
what like basic data types are. um you
need to know what memory is and how it's
allocated
and I don't know that's about it.
C is a very small small toolkit and it's
mostly about just clear simple logic.
I don't have jazz I don't think I have a
bunch of streams where I've done a bunch
like there might be some if you go back
but I'm going to be doing more of these
reviews anyways.
like this was a good one for today.
But you see how I just kind of go
through and I piece through things and I
just like, okay, can this be done more
simply? All right, you're looping over
this like do you need to actually be
looping over this thing? Do you need to
be doing operations proportional to map
size here? You know, you just simplify.
C is an amazing language. See the
problem with modern programming, right?
You get these really bloated languages
that go like tool tool tool library like
paradigm box other box that contains
other box I don't tell you what's in box
blah and everything is very weird and
like it just doesn't feel like logic
problem like solve in simplest way
possible done fast right what is
computer doing I don't know
with C it gives you like five things and
you can solve whatever the hell you want
with them and And then very often times
you look at your code at the end of the
day and it's like a thousand times
faster than the stupid JavaScript thing
that somebody wrote and it's shorter and
it's simpler.
Add two integers at the end. I replied
to that. Yes, just like add two integers
at the end. I think it's three integers,
right? It's X, Y, and num boxes or
something.
Unless I miss some.
I don't think it might have eaten
messages. If you don't see it on the
stream, I didn't see your message,
though.
All right, I'm happy with that. That was
a good reveal.
Don't you make the MC?
Yeah, you make the M and C.
There's not that much to know.
Map licenses.
Oh, for [ __ ] sake. Are the maps CC
BSA?
Uh,
that's going to be a problem if they
are. We can still use the autogen ones.
Let's see what what are the map gen
licenses.
Well, wait. You have some most of them
are autogen, right?
Yeah, it's just the assets, man.
So, nicks those.
Oh, and uh
I didn't check. Is it a puffer pushing
the boxes? You get bonus points if it's
a puffer pushing the boxes.
Yeah, I think mostly Tim like you know
make sure that you do the refactors when
you're fresh because I think that in
terms of like density of learning this
one project will teach you a huge huge
amount like you'll really really change
a lot of the things that you think about
in programming uh from this
Okay. Uh, that's a good review. Cool.
That didn't take that long. Licensed
maps are harder.
It's just Apache. Apache is fine.
Okay, cool. Um, here's what we're going
to do, folks. This was good code review.
Oh, I do these for everybody, by the
way. So if you submit a useful end
that's not just like claw code crap that
you've put zero effort into. So if you
actually are trying to learn this stuff,
you want to get involved or you know you
like you're going to make a useful
environment, I do code reviews. I get
behind on the code reviews all the time
because I have a lot of other work to
do. But I do eventually do them and I do
them live and you know you get feedback
and commentary like this and you get
more feedback and commentary if it's an
actually useful environment as well.
Like so bondism is a absolutely kick-ass
environment for research. It's a really
really good exploration task. Um uh the
one thing I'm not sure about Tim is
whether I'm going to have you do local
like partial observations or not on the
end. I think we'll try it with global
obs. So just clean it up with global obs
and then we'll look at it after. Uh, I'm
going to go get myself a mug of tea and
then we are going to work on the logging
code for Puffer 4 so that we can get our
logs in a nice clean format to load into
Constellation for visualization. We're
going to get some experiments up and
running and then later today once I
finish all of that, we're going to start
reviewing uh some low-level code, all
the CUDA code for Puffer 4, and I'm
going to see what else I can clean up
because that portion of the codebase is
a total total mess. I will be back in a
few.
So,
metrics
Let me have uh some tea and I'm going to
think just for a few moments about how I
want to set this up. I'm going to
implement the curves
really simple be done by a newbie.
Soon's only a few hundred lines. Soon is
going to end up being a top five end.
Soon is you should have some programming
experience before you do something like
so. I wouldn't recommend it to a new
programmer, but that's perfectly a good
project for somebody who's like new to
lowlevel and um new to RL.
Like 2048 is another example. 2048 ended
up being a fantastic environment. It
just like a lot of the tasks that are
end up being scalable difficulty, you
know, where like you can kind of get a
reasonable solution quite quickly, but
there's a lot of depth to them and
they're like difficulty scalable. Those
end up being very good.
partial obs why it can make it easier to
have it be centered on the agent
sometimes but the main reason Tim is
just for the uh the bandwidth and the
amount of data going into the neural net
like as you make the maps bigger first
of all you have to train on all the same
size maps And second of all, if they get
too big, it's going to slow it down.
Don't worry about that now, though, man.
Just clean up the end. You got enough to
do. You're going to learn a ton from
doing that, believe me.
Don't worry too much about the um the
Python C API like the pi dict pi this pi
that that's all getting removed in um in
40. That thing's a mess. [ __ ] Python.
So come on all 10 x 10. 10 x 10 is fine.
Then we can just do globals.
But if we solve all the maps in 10 by
10, Tim, we might want to make them
bigger.
You won't.
Buffer is pretty good.
We kind of soda the crap out of
everything we touch. So, I don't know.
I'll send you a puffer. Don't send me a
puffer fish.
I move around too much to be taking care
of a puffer fish. I would have gotten
several by now if I wanted to.
I can't solve them. Oh, there's a lot of
stuff I can't do that the agent can do.
Man, it took me like it took me um I
don't know, maybe four or five hours of
practice to learn how to park a car over
the last couple of days. I guarantee you
we can RL an agent to park perfectly in
three seconds if we just set up a
scenario in the puffer drive. Like, it's
completely trivial for RL.
Look, in my defense, the uh the test
they put the cones all the way at the
end of a white line. It's like It's like
parking between two [ __ ] Ford pickup
drivers and they have just completely
boxed you in.
Come puffer RL. Get me girls. RL can gym
training is considered a form of
reinforcement learning, right? You lift
weight. You observe weight. You lift
weight. You pick up weight. You get
strong.
I am still doing work here. I'm just
thinking about how I want to do this.
Like this is very important that I get
the logging format right.
I'm trying to think how I want to do
basically the final evaluation versus
the intermediate evaluations.
I think it would just be better to have
them all merged, right?
Oh, wait. That's easy.
That's easy.
What we're going to try to do here
basically is get all the metrics nicely
down sampled into log file.
I'm just like messing with this a little
bit. See if there's a better way to do
it.
Yeah, I hate this as well. Go away,
Claude. You're dumb.
We append.
Well, we do have data for all of these.
Oh, I know how it works. That's not
good.
No, this is not what we want.
Yeah, I answered my own question in my
head. This is not what we want.
Oh, wait. Does this work?
Yes, this does work.
I don't think that we can actually do
that.
This is freaking cool. This here is
cool.
Um,
involve signal. Gian window simple
moving average
I'm just playing around with different
down sampling things at the moment
because um it's super important that we
have this right.
Like this is the most important thing.
Okay,
so
Yeah, there should not be this is
optimistic.
The problem
I think we're going to end up at the
exact spot that we just started at,
aren't we? Which is just a mean filter.
I'm just playing with um interps with
this guys because like it's really
really important that we have good
curves.
Like if your debug tool is wrong, it's
really hard to debug.
None of this code's getting used. This
is just for me playing around with
methods.
Okay, this is way better, right?
Yeah. Look, it's not biased anymore.
This is an unbiased sample. Way better.
Why does this point get pulled
this getting dragged up as normal,
right?
There's no reason to preserve the first
point.
Is there a reason to preserve the first
point?
What do we think, guys? I mean, we're
never going to use a window this size.
Realistically, what? It's 100 points, so
we'd use what, like 10.
This is perfect, right?
20 would be the most.
Good morning.
Not enough people making graphs on
YouTube. Oh, this is super easy crap.
So, I'm just messing around here with
different interpolation metrics. The
reason for this is here. Let me explain
what I'm doing.
So, I'm cleaning up Puffer 4's logging
code. And uh all this code is going to
get pulled into constellation.
Show you constellation,
which is our new
C native dashboard. Lots of metrics.
Every single point is an experiment. Uh
can just have huge huge amounts of data
and analysis in here. It's all
incredibly quick. It doesn't lag like
the stupid web UIs, right?
um because it's all just native in C.
It'll run in your browser as well uh
just with web assembly. Uh the thing
that I'm trying to figure out is when
I'm logging data to it, we we down
sample the data so that we don't have
huge log files and it's really important
that that interpolation for that be done
well because otherwise you completely
mess up all your analysis. So I'm uh
none of this code for this plot here is
getting used. This is just me messing
around with different interpolation
metrics in Claude. Um, and I think that
this is what we like, which is very
close to what we already have.
It's very, very close to what we already
have. And I think this is what we're
going to integrate.
But I'm just kind of taking it slow and
being very careful because this is it's
very important this be done correctly.
This is going to be a little bit
difficult though, isn't it?
Okay. Realistically, what's going to be
missing, right?
We'll always have lost data.
We can always have perf data.
This is just the end data that could be
missing, right?
Do you use Nvidia Isaac Sim?
It's going to be popular soon.
I mean, that is incredibly popular, but
I'm not doing robotics at the moment. We
do reinforcement learning. We do some
control, but we don't do a ton of like
high fidelity robotic stuff. Um, we do a
lot more industrial sim. We use a lot of
games for research. They work very well
across the board and we build a high
performance low-level tools in RL. I
mean, you see Python here, but the
entire training code is all in CUDA,
like raw CUDA.
We'll be editing that later today as
well. There'll be some CUDA refactoring
on stream. I'm going to be live all day
long on this,
minus a couple quick breaks for food and
stuff here and there.
I'm going to try to not starve myself
today. I usually forget to eat on stream
while I'm streaming all day.
That can happen with improper log
frequency. That can happen with a lot of
stuff, can't it?
Well, first of all, is there any way we
can make it not happen?
Hang on. We Let's think about this. The
best way to solve a problem is to like
bypass the problem in the first place.
So,
in what situations are we just not going
to have log data?
There are some environments that simply
take more than one epoch worth of
training to have reasonable log metrics.
No way around that, right?
I'm also not a huge fan of just
accumulating these blogs, though.
Yeah, you can literally OM with the
logs, can't you? They get really big for
the long runs.
Okay, so we have to think about how
we're doing this a little bit more
carefully.
stream shows up on shorts.
That's weird.
I made a couple as an experiment and
then I just decided it's not it's just
not a format I really like. I don't
think shorts are like a good or healthy
format for stuff.
Hey, Winker. Um,
it's going decently. I'm just trying to
figure out at the moment like there's
some edge cases with how we do logging
and I'd like to get it done correctly
now so I can stop messing with it and
stop having to rerun experiments.
So, I'm going to just spend the time
today to actually do it correctly and
then we're going to be set.
Okay. Okay, so there are a couple weird
things, right? So like one, some runs
are really long.
We can solve that just by down sampling
uh the log data every once in a while.
So we can ignore that problem.
Runs that don't return in data at all
should just get deleted.
I guess the only thing left is the Ms
that do return and log data that just
don't do it often Enough.
This is not the uh shipped code for
reference. Like I would not put this in
the shipped code. This is just me
playing with interp
for chess. Transitions end games to real
games over learning. It'll sometimes
miss a mate.
transition end games to real games.
We laced a lot of time for it to learn
the goal.
Um, I wouldn't worry too much, Jess,
because like the curriculum problem will
be solved by Puffer 5.
So, I would instead of trying to like do
a bunch of stuff to figure out the
different phases of the game, I would
focus more on like making sure that
you've actually done the architecture
and encoder ablations. Get it as simple
as possible. Uh, you know, get the thing
training as fast as possible. If you can
figure out the like two pick phase
versus one phase thing, figure out if
you're wasting 25 or 75% of the compute,
you know, with weird selfplay hacks.
Like that's the stuff that's going to
matter because the main goal for chess,
right? We get this ELO curve and we do
pretty damn well on it and we can use it
as a like the main thing is that the end
has to not be jank, right? Like we want
this to be something that we can
actually use in a run. We have several
M's that are just jank that we don't use
as often in research even though they're
really cool.
Um
so as long as we can get that then the
goal will be uh as we move to puffer 5
you know we'll be implementing new
curriculum stuff and then chess will
become a test environment in which we
see whether our curriculum stuff helps
because we would expect it to in chess
and then we can report better ELO curves
over time. So, I wouldn't wait I
wouldn't worry too too much about like
hacking the CL. You can do a little bit
of stuff, but like 50 bill steps is not
that much for chess. Like I'm not
surprised that it's going to take more
than 50 bill steps. And when we get it
actually efficient uh so that it's
running at the speed we it should be
running, we can just send a one trill
like we can send a one trill run on
chess and that can be the baseline.
campman filter.
You just Yeah, you just sample it.
Okay. Yeah, you wouldn't mean filter.
You just sample it.
I'm basically I'm just messing around
with different interpolation methods
here and I'm seeing if there's a way to
do this cleanly.
See like this is too much mess.
Okay, let me see what this is doing.
Sorted
I think this I think it's just [ __ ]
this up entirely.
Hang on. I have to how I want to
proceed.
hidden size always been the biggest elo
boost. Don't want to go over 512. 256
being the default in my mind.
Uh you're on the 30 architecture though,
Jeff. So 40 it'll be easier to scale.
Wait, does it matter that you have it
sampled?
It does matter that they get sampled
onto the same axis, right?
Does that have to be a particular key?
It does, right? It has to be a
particular key that you always have.
Any of the keys will work.
See what we're left with.
So this filter up
encoder and arch. Should I be thinking
of those as separate in my mind? Um,
only because of the amount of work I've
done in 40 on uh the minbased like main
network versus LSTM just
Like the main network is a pretty nice
buff.
To be fair, I have not seen it do
massively better at anything yet, but it
is just so much faster. It's really nice
and it should in theory it should scale
better for bigger nets.
specific obs format saw a mass hidden
size and then I died. Um,
you could time it in torch to see the
CNN like one layer versus
uh MLP. How big is the hidden size?
The only annoying thing with coms is you
will depend on QDNN for them.
National Masters.
Well, we have an upper bound now.
Wait, what do you mean three hidden
layers for the first two layers?
What do you mean for the first two
layers? Three hidden layers for the
first two layers.
Three layers total.
So two hidden layers.
So wait, that's 4 million 8 million.
That's only 9 million parameters. Jess,
was that the entire network?
We can train 9 million parameters well
over a million steps per second
need this function to be plain and I
think we can be good.
I'm going to take my break um get some
food quite soon.
But let's keep going for a little bit.
Few more minutes on this
I don't understand this Kum. I think
this is going to be the thing next
to do.
I'm going to go take a quick break. I
got to go do a couple quick. I'll be
back and we will clean this up.
Oh man, I don't like having bits of code
like this in the code base. Even if it's
just for something like down sampling,
we need to get this op correct. It's
worth spending time on this today, even
if it's like a bunch of line of time for
a few lines. Um,
I'll be back shortly. Uh, star puffer on
GitHub if you haven't already. It helps
me out a lot. I will leave stream on.
I'll be back soon.
after adding. We're not planning on
adding search calamaria.
We're trying to do it without search.
That's the point.
Got myself some toast. We're going to
think about this function a little bit
for down sample. It's very very basic,
but it's like it's one of those things
you really have to get right. So I think
that today is the day that we just spend
the time to get it right.
So, the first thing I'm wondering is
whether or not this
this array logic makes it actually more
complicated.
You can totally add search.
Search is just incredibly slow.
I personally don't think search is going
to be the way forward generally.
Um I honestly think within the next
couple years we're going to have RL just
working out of the box on medium
complexity problems like problems that
we do professionally now um for clients
we're pretty much going to just be able
to have the learning portion work out of
the box. You know there's going to still
be some intricacies to sim uh simulation
development but it's going to be much
easier. There going to be far fewer
places where stuff can go wrong. The
learning will be way better. Everything
will be massively more efficient and
simpler and we're going to be able to
start really pushing this stuff on hard
problems.
I mean, that's just like how I see it
going with Puffer, cuz I don't see many
other people doing stuff, frankly, at
this point.
I'm just comparing a couple things with
this on how we could do our um our
indexing, you
far am I getting?
Well, I don't need one for here. I'm at
my family's place. Um, realistically,
everywhere I go, they're just far as I
can borrow.
Now, if Tesla ships the uh the
autonomous cyber cap
and it's at a reasonable price, I might
get one of those.
That sounds fun.
I got my license so I can drive. I don't
expect to enjoy driving or want to do it
much. It's just like right now I can do
it and like I no longer have to be stuck
every so often.
Like realistically, I'm just going to
use the self-driving stuff 95 plus% of
the time.
I mean, my family already has, you know,
one I can just borrow. Um,
I I guess it depends when they actually
end up shipping the cab version.
That's like fully autonomous
like I pretty much just got the license.
So, um cuz it's currently it's
supervised and it's not fully
autonomous.
So, You need to at least be able to
drive to the standards of the state
driving test,
which I did in 3 days.
I mean, in my mind, driving was just a
chore in the first place.
approve for safety without a manual
control option.
I mean, it's actually stupid that like
the things haven't been approved already
considering that they are um
they're safer than the median driver.
Like as soon as something is safer than
the median of whatever it is, like
you're actively killing people by
leaving it off the road.
It's actually quite difficult to uh to
do this correctly
like without introducing any sort of
weird biases.
Your selection of default coding
standards.
It's hard to be prescriptive with stuff.
Shorter code is generally better. as
long as you're not golfing the crap out
of it. Um,
less abstraction is better, less
indirection is better.
And you can't just like put coding
standards. It's not like, you know, cuz
any like boiler plate I give you,
there's going to be a stupid way to do
it.
It's just generally do stuff top to
bottom in the simplest way possible.
Okay, this I do have to decide on. And
this is actually quite annoying because
it gets so much easier if I can just
assume that we have data
indirection.
So a function is ind direction, right?
Like anything that is not the exact code
that you top to bottom introduces a
layer of indirection. So when you split
something out into a function, it's a
layer of indirection because then you
have to go into the function to go look
for the thing, right?
Classes indirection as well.
Anything that puts the control flow of
the program somewhere else. Indirection
is also used as a technical term for
like lookups and stuff. Um so you can
also use it to mean that as like a term
for performance analysis like number of
jumps and stuff, but I'm just referring
to it generally as
the amount of layers between you and the
thing you care about.
So you'll often see me like fighting for
hours to remove a layer of indirection,
meaning like this function calls this
function calls this function. Can I have
it be two deep instead of three?
stuff like that
Hey and neglect. Welcome. Trying to ship
Puffer 4 and I'm currently cleaning up
our logging. Uh there's one last thing I
have to do on our logging so it's nice
and clean and so we can like actually
have our experiments run without me
having to change this thing constantly.
That's what I've been up to mostly.
Hey
I really do not like this. So it's the
only issue that we have really is like
the experiments where you get basically
no data
really short experiments.
We could just regard those as onepoint
experiments.
19%
win rate at 35 mil steps.
That's fun.
That's pretty cool.
Pick loves draws. Of course it loves
draws. It's way easier to figure out how
to draw it apparently. And it gets
points.
frames in billions.
Okay, so this is using a,00x more
compute.
Oh, I actually can't tell.
Hang on a second.
I don't know how the 10 to the zero
baseline works. That doesn't make any
sense.
So they're using 100x
cute.
Oh, it's trained using 100 simulations.
We hit 200k in literally 18 minutes, so
I think we're good. Thank you.
See?
Yay, it works.
Five.
Okay,
there we go.
Good. And caught the mistake.
Like that was obviously wrong before,
right?
Good.
Play the new Resident Evil. No, dude. So
I I sit here and I write code.
This is not a uh a game stream.
What a swallow
for D and data
that
we're going to get this thing not be
[ __ ] The sample function is very
important.
I don't care that we're spending four
hours on a like a 10 line sample
function. Like that's just what it's
going to be today.
It's like Python brain garbage here, I
swear.
It might be Jess. I have no idea how
complex or how scaling how much it
scales.
you're probably better off with chess
and if you want to do other games like I
I wouldn't recommend doing more of these
like hard to intuit it puzzle ends. Um
we have a few of them already. The ones
we have are like we have a few that are
easy enough to interpret.
Um,
like there are other big projects we can
do for sure for ends.
Don't get me wrong.
What is this garbage?
Let me let me go. First of all, is this
even correct?
No, this is not even correct.
pure fine. I'm getting a robot car with
claw and I want to train with buffer.
Um,
honestly the next like selfplay there
are a couple of these like tank games
that are fun for control. Robocode would
be a good one to finish. Nobody's ever
finished that. Oh, look for open PRs in
case anybody did some stuff on it
though. Um,
honestly, the really big end that I'm
going to want long term is like full
MMO.
There's definitely some stuff we can do
that's uh in the like in the middle
though. Do you go to the gym every day?
The latest block of training I've done
has not been super great. I've kind of
just been doing a ton of work on Puffer
4. Um I at the moment I'm going three
times a week. One day I'm doing like a
good run. I was doing a good run three
times a week, but then I just couldn't
keep up with the lifting. I have some
pretty good um some pretty good gym
training going on. I've got like a
really good trainer. Um
it's like a pretty heavy
it's not full powerlifting block.
I'm trying to round out a bunch of stuff
actually at the moment because I had a
couple injuries. Uh I got to fix my
shoulder. I'm putting some pounds back
on my bench.
I'll probably be back to doing stuff
every day when I'm back in Maryland.
Where do we get keys from?
It's actually kind of bad. That's
We do not have keys.
Oh, wait. Could I make it way easier?
I could make it way easier on myself
here, couldn't I?
would you give letters of wreck for
that?
Um, init I think it would be very
difficult generally to do that.
I did that in a time when RL was way
more active and uh I had an advisor
going into it that I'd already worked
with for quite a while at OpenAI
and I think these days like
I don't think that there's as much of a
reason to turn an end into a PhD
anymore. I kind of already did that.
I think mostly that problem is solved.
I would definitely give letters of wreck
though to like um major contributors
who've done a bunch of stuff.
I think generally you want letters of
wreck from professors, but I mean mine
would carry some weight at the least.
It kind of depends.
that harder than working at a frontier
lab.
Um, well, yeah, but those companies have
gotten so big that like they have a lot
of stupid people there just by
definition.
like companies just don't get to that
size and scale well, right?
Like I think that the vast majority of
the people at OpenAI when I was there
were very good.
I definitely wasn't one of them yet. You
know, I had a couple things that I knew
that like I had some pretty good ideas
that other people weren't thinking
about, but I definitely wasn't as
generally competent uh as many of the
people there when I was there.
Obviously, I was like 20.
But they don't keep you don't keep
talent density and scale. Just doesn't
work.
Okay, I have it. I have this totally
screwed up. Don't
I feel like so stupid with this
function, but like this is actually just
very important that I do this correctly
and there's a little bit of subtlety for
it. So again, it's like if we spend half
a day on this, whatever, it's a
worthwhile investment.
Oh,
stupid.
MIT PhD struggles with incredibly basic
ass logic, but then again, the LM made a
massive mess of it, too. So,
whatever, you know?
Wow, I really messed that up. I was told
the LMS are better than an MIT PhD. Now
the LMS are really dumb.
I think the correct interpretation is LM
can't reason. Most people can't reason.
Reasoning is refer is res is reserved
for some people sometimes.
I think I can sometimes reason,
you know, if I'm fresh and not just
being a total goober for no reason.
I mean, actually, an like being me,
that's pretty much what it feels like
all the time. I don't feel like I'm a
genius or anything. Like, I feel like
I'm pretty stupid and most of the time
I'm just barely competent enough to do
the [ __ ] I need to do and then it feels
like everybody else is just sitting
around eating crayons on repeat.
That's uh kind of what it feels like.
Like every so often I'll solve something
that's like, man, that was a hard
problem that needed me to be pretty
clever to come up with that. But most of
the time it's just like, oh my gosh, we
have all over complicated the crap out
of everything. This should be simple.
We're all just dumb. That's kind of just
what it feels like.
I've never had the imposttor syndrome
thing where it's like, oh, it seems like
everybody else is so smart. It It's I've
kind of had the opposite thing where
it's like, wow, we're all really,
really, really dumb.
My philosophy is pretty damn basic in
it. Me write code heavy rock eat big
steak.
delete Tik Tok immediately.
Delete Tik Tok. Delete Instagram if you
have those. X is a necessary evil. Try
not to scroll that too much. X is a
necessary evil.
But yeah.
the one total life activity that I have
where it's just like, you know, I didn't
do it for three years and then I made a
bunch of progress on puffer and I just
wanted to have something nice to do when
I feel like taking some time off as I do
have my Runescape here. That's basically
it.
And I think I just kind of got stressed
out with X chip just having gone to
total [ __ ] It's like the AI grifters
trying to out grift each other to raise
all the money and whatever.
And I just don't give a [ __ ] I just
want to do my stuff. We advance science
and all the Hollywood wannabes can just
do their thing over there in SF
while eating my lunch. Fair enough.
Fair enough.
I don't like having this be a deep polic
at all.
All right. This code sucks here, but
like already this is the same length as
what we had before and it's simpler.
So, I think we're going to be able to
make use of this.
This actually is going to end up pretty
close to what we had originally, but
there is a crucial there are a couple
crucial distinctions that will make this
better.
I mean, I really like I don't think that
the university that you go to really
matters for what you can do long term.
It only really matters with um
it's mostly a bonus with conventional
path stuff, right? So, conventional job
applications, conventional fundraising,
this and that.
But if you're kind of just like building
awesome stuff and doing your own thing,
things become a lot more meritocratic
quite quickly.
Couple of the best people I know came
from like I have no idea where
There we go.
So, this is now correct.
Now, we just have to
Now we have to simplify this. Use the
restroom real quick and get a refill on
my tea. I'll be back in just a couple of
minutes, folks.
Every time I come in, dude's away.
I got to get tea once an hour or so,
man. I intentionally um I intentionally
make it so I have to go downstairs. So I
don't just sit here for 12 hours a day
straight.
My music back.
There we are.
All right.
So this function works.
It's just a mess.
Let me just think about it a little bit.
See if we can clean this up.
This has to be the outer loop, right?
How can I concentrate listening to
music? Is it with lyrics?
Um,
very little if any.
I'm not really a music guy.
I'm not like, you know, indie music.
I think I've been to one concert in my
life, like ever. Maybe two. I think two.
Both of which I was dragged to.
I didn't go I didn't join any of the
fraternities, but I went to plenty of
parties.
I think if we we would do it slightly
different in C, but I think this is
fine, right?
Drink less.
Yeah.
I mean, realistically,
that was just because I'd like I'd
basically never done anything fun in
that way in my whole life. And uh I
figured I probably wouldn't be, you
know, I'd be doing serious research and
[ __ ] I wasn't going to be traveling
around partying. So
now I don't regret having some fun in
college. I still did plenty of work. I
published my first paper uh paper single
author. Did the work for that. Start of
my sophomore year. I finished the whole
core of Stanford CS curriculum my first
year.
still graduated. I took time off to do
um Open AI and I still graduated early.
I could have been way more efficient
with everything as well.
I think I was very very stubborn like I
would just not ask for help on stuff
even when the spec was just completely
ambiguous.
Full Stanford CS and gen one year. Well,
look.
It's literally one, two, three, four,
five, six courses. All right. So,
typically people will take one of these
um they'll take like one or two of like
they'll take one of these. They'll take
two or three of these a quarter. So
they'll typically they'll finish they'll
put this one off usually. So usually
people finish this their junior year.
Some people do it their senior year. I
just said, "Okay, I have, you know, I've
got six courses. I've got three
quarters. I'll do two of them per
quarter and I'm done.
I probably should have paid more
attention to my probability and stats
courses cuz I don't know [ __ ] about
that. I don't know. Stats like stats
just never made any bloody sense to me
at all.
Yeah. So, that's what I did, Roger. I
started doing full-time research as soon
as I got to my second year.
So, I would basically do like 40 hours
of research a week and then I'd have 40
hours for my classes.
I did a couple other crazy things as
well.
I mean, that's like not impressive
though at all.
Like, I was not a great student. I
intentionally didn't put in the time to
get like straight A's in all the courses
either.
something you can instill?
Uh, I worked 110 hours a week through
high school, Jess. Going from that to
like 80 or 90 a week in college and
actually being able to sleep was
comparatively much easier.
Like the concept of having a night off
didn't even exist to me before that. So
I don't recommend anybody do that. Uh
you will be miserable.
But it does make it easy to do what most
people would be considered working
pretty hard. Like I feel lazy now with
the amount of hours that I put in
by comparison.
How come? Doing what? That's just what
it takes in the US um to like ensure
that you get into undergrad.
You can get lucky
um not working as hard.
Is my competition invoked?
I mean, that's how you ensure that you
get in somewhere um while not being a
genius
and going to a specific place. I
probably could have worked, you know,
substantially less and gotten into an IV
or whatever.
Like very very little has come to me
naturally.
would call you a genius.
I don't know.
But I'm like, what I mean by that,
right, is it's not like stuff was just
easy.
Not really, Roger.
Like
the other oper the other option which is
what I had was you basically you get to
be 20 and you realize that you're
completely socially inept because you
spent zero time doing anything but
studying.
You basically end up with the character
development of a 13-year-old by the time
you're 18 or 19.
I honestly think a lot of people like in
CS if you just follow the stuff in my
guide, you'll get yourself several
thousand hours back for free anyways
that you would have wasted on basically
like trying to get good and doing so
very inefficiently.
Oh, I did a whole bunch of stupid [ __ ]
Jess.
I would intentionally go do like a whole
bunch of stupid [ __ ] just for the hell
of it.
But honestly, that was not the most
difficult thing. I think the most
difficult thing for me was like, you
know, getting to that point and then
realizing that most of the people around
me were just completely like lacking in
any sort of ambition
and uh really had no desire to advance
tech or produce anything meaningful
whatsoever.
I'm kind of realizing that like there
simply just aren't places um that are
very dense in those types of people
because there are very few of them.
Like a good chunk of PhD candidates
don't even care about advancing their
field, believe it or not.
things make a lot more sense. Once you
understand that
Open source is really fun for that as
well.
Right.
I think this function is good.
Hey, does anybody see anything wrong
with this?
Anybody see anything we can shorten?
Let me explain why this function is like
this, right? Let me explain.
Even 10% is close to you 28. What should
I be doing?
You should be working on the right
stuff. I mean, I can only speak to my
field, but like
the the commentary I have on science
like on science and how science is done
is very important to understand.
Like essentially there's a set there's a
set of reasons
once you start getting deeply technical
especially in RL but I assume so in many
other fields as well like everything is
super [ __ ] up and you have to actually
understand the external reasons for why
stuff is incredibly [ __ ] up and you
know why actually know people have spent
thousands and thousands and thousands of
hours doing this type of work but what
you need to do is not beat them at that
type of work. You need to do something
completely different.
Um,
that is a skill that I don't know if I
would say it came naturally to me.
That's just something that I've sort of
always been thinking about from the
start. You know, how do I push the field
forward? How do I push the field
forward? And looking at stuff from that
perspective rather than a much narrower
how do I solve this one little problem
over many years. Uh, I draw a lot of
connections that other people do not.
And for instance, you know, I can see,
okay, well, look, the whole field of RL
hyperfocused in on the sample efficiency
problem. We don't even know if this
problem makes any sense. Look at this.
All the code is incredibly inefficient.
We're running stuff 10,000 times slower
than it could be based on napkin math of
the hardware. Um, you know, everything
feels incredibly janky and unstable, and
we honestly don't know why. So what
happens if we spend a little bit of time
trying to optimize the throughput for
the hardware and we stop focusing in so
much on this thing that everybody else
has looked at and very very quickly once
I started doing that the path sort of
just opened up and lo and behold like
there were a ton of advancements there
just sitting to be made that I didn't
need to be a genius to make. I just had
to learn a few relatively simple things
with low-level dev and to keep at it for
a couple of years. And now ours is super
fast and lo and behold uh training with
larger batches and training with these
numbers of samples makes everything more
efficient right so it's that type of a
thing right where it's I didn't just go
and beat the field at their own game I
realized they were solving the wrong
problem
so that's one of the things now the
second thing is uh the fundamental
skills that you need I think that I
spent a lot a lot of time trying to
become a good programmer I was doing it
very inefficiently because I didn't do
low-level dev early enough, right?
Because my undergrad courses really
threw me off of low-level dev. They
taught it very very poorly. Um, so I
didn't want to do any low-level dev. But
I still spent a lot of years just trying
to figure out how do I write cleaner
code? How do I make stuff simpler,
right? How do I do stuff without making
such a mess? And as a result, when I did
start doing low-level code, it was
incredibly easy and natural to me. You
know, it only took me like a few weeks
before I was super comfortable just
jamming everything in C. Um so
programming fundamentals write simple
just writing simple efficient code
basics basics of what your computer is
actually doing some level of math um
fundamentals of deep learning at the
very least like it's just that mostly
it's fundamentals in a few areas plus um
plus perspective for the most part and
then having the time to actually devote
to doing this over many years.
Let me explain that what this function
is to everybody and let's just see if
anybody has any quick suggestions. So,
uh why did I spend 5 hours on a like 15
line Python super basic sampling
function? Well, we needed something to
downsample log data and we needed to not
make a mess of the logs. So what I
eventually came to the conclusion of is
we can simply not include anything in
all logs that does not contain
environment log data because environment
log data is not kept every step. Um we
need this to m uh if this is a very
short array we need this to preserve the
original structure.
Okay. And if it's a long array it needs
to be down sampled to end points in
equal bins. So what this does is it just
chunks up total time steps into a fixed
number of bins and it averages all the
data within those numbers of time steps.
Um
that's literally all it does. Oh and it
preserves the end point. It uses that
last point at the very end. This
division means that if we have n equals
10 points, we will naturally just get
the first point at 5%, the last point at
95% and then the final eval at 100%.
Which is very nice spacing. If we pass
fewer points than all logs, it doesn't
get down sampled and this will return
the exact original data
which is very important that you don't
like resample your data.
Anybody see any improvements we can make
to this or any problems?
Off's more sample efficient but very
slow. Is there something There is
something intrinsic that makes slow just
I had that exact question and I spent
six weeks over the summer studying it.
I wrote an article on it as well.
My conclusion was that off Paul is
screwed unless somebody solves this very
tricky mathematical problem that I don't
even know if there is a way to solve
fundamentally.
There's essentially this fundamental gap
between on and off policy. You can't
just have it be like a little bit off
policy and then spend a little bit more
compute and have smoothly better
results. As far as I've seen,
The only thing that you're running out
of time for is um not being inundated by
people giving you absolutely terrible
advice on stuff.
Most of the people that are earlier on
would just be best served by jamming
some nice low-level dev, you know,
developing some fundamental skills,
building some cool stuff. If you're into
AI, learn some actual fundamentals,
apply them to real projects.
basically it
double for loops.
Uh no Jess this is fundamental to the
problem right you have a certain number
of logs and a certain number of keys
see.
We have to fix the losses.
Here's the restroom real quick.
We just have to fix losses.
dude. What the [ __ ] is this doing?
Stupid.
Wait. Episode length times agents
divided by
Um,
well, we just had a pretty nice one.
I wouldn't say it's that large, but we
did just come up with a very nice
hardware efficient architecture in
Puffer 4,
which makes everything quite a bit
faster and a little bit more scalable.
It's a pretty funny one as well.
It's a combination of two quite niche
papers.
I like this.
I like how we have it here.
I'll explain what I'm doing here like
the the thinking behind this in a
moment. Let me get my thoughts down
fully.
It has to do with the final evaluation
and logging.
refactoring architecture of open source
puffer.
Well, at the moment, Garcia, um,
I mean, I'm the creator of Puffer, so
there's quite a bit of refactor work to
be done during the process of
development, especially for a major new
release. At the moment, I'm actually um
this is a little bit more than a
cleanup. This is going to improve the
robustness of our logging. Um this is
going to make it a lot easier to get log
data into our dashboard. It'll make it
quite a bit more concise.
It's a little bit more than just a
refactor at the moment.
Now the main thing that we have is the
architecture is now sequable.
Uh it's like sequal in training which is
very very nice and it's a little bit
more scalable. It's got some nice
properties to it.
We got a bunch of nice efficient
implementation stuff around it as well
and be made even faster as well.
Like in theory once we uh with a really
good implementation it should be
essentially as fast as the mat op that
it does
very very little overhead on top of the
one mat.
structure.
I'd need to know more about the problem
to say anything useful.
methodologies and architectures.
Uh there are papers.
It depends on the industry and how um
know how modernized it is.
Like in driving for instance, there's a
ton of stuff on driving.
value loss explosion to nan when I
increase hidden sizes the optimal
learning rate changes Spencer it's not
invariant to model size until we do mu
better updates in J
it is OP Conan but it's also like the
fact that everything is resting on that
and that is like the entire thing that
is making anything work means it's worth
investigating.
I wrote a very nice blog post about this
actually where it really is the case
that J is the only reason that um
anything in RL works.
It's the long it's the long for
bootstrap
there this one.
So this is basically the bridge between
on and off policy and um essentially
like you just cannot do long form
bootstrap off policy. J requires that
you have on Paul data or very close to
onpaul data. All correction forms are
basically ignore off-paul data in
disguise.
And this is the reason that off is so
freaking slow.
Oh, I see
the problem.
take a break in 15 minutes or so.
Quick, I'm starting to feel myself
slipping a little mentally,
but this is getting there. It's getting
there.
Yes, it would, Jess.
It would be
one of the things on the list.
I have not taken the time to go through
the and understand the correction
factor.
Got all logs.
Yeah.
All right. So,
almost there.
It would be so nice to combine this,
wouldn't it?
We could do Eval rollouts.
That'd be interesting.
Okay, I have an idea. We could we
actually might be able to simplify a lot
of this.
We will see.
I'm going to take a quick break,
clear my head out, grab uh some toast,
get a more tea, and I will be right
back. I think we might be able to
combine the two loops.
One moment, folks. I'll get myself set
back up here.
A quick hamburger.
my kid. No, I'm at my family's place.
Leftover.
I can make breakfast and I can grill a
steak. That's about it.
Okay.
So, what I was thinking here
is maybe we can fuse these two loops.
Going to just get rid of flaw here so
we're not tempted to use it.
says the problem is we clear it when we
log
This has to also go here. Now, I'm just
going to play with this a little bit. I
want to see if we can cleanly fuse the
loops.
It's actually quite difficult to clean
this up.
It's worth doing.
Yeah, there's no clotting this or
anything. This is just like straight.
All right. Well, it's worth the time.
It's worth the time.
Do this properly.
It's the main training loop after all.
something comfortable.
A full project to work on.
Okay,
let's see.
So weird, man.
This
all the things I got to do.
Okay, we just ignore this,
right?
It's easy stuff. It's just like
we really need to do this correctly.
All right. We're working on real
robotics. It works.
Just use him to train. Yeah. So, there's
that whole spat with um Kyle on the
recent Twitter thread on that. Um,
apparently people in robotics do really
stupid domain randomization, which I
believe because I've seen some of their
code
done properly. Like domain randomization
and curriculum learning is the tool that
you use for complex RL problems.
yeah, but this doesn't get passed as
star quarks.
Like, it's not quar.
You wouldn't really want it to be
either.
Well, I mean that's what it is.
It's not star arcs. It's not farts.
I'm I have to fix the structure of this
first. Like the structure of this is the
important thing right now.
It's not complicated, but it's a very
important piece of code and it needs to
be as simple as it can possibly be.
What am I doing here? This is like This
should be so simple.
This checkpoint needs to be done at a
different time, right?
Are you working on a PR?
I'm working on refactoring and cleaning
up the training as well as improving the
sampling logic for logging.
It's my project. I just kind of merge
what the [ __ ] I want to the dev
branches, right?
meant a PR review. No, I did uh I
reviewed an end earlier this morning.
This is my code.
It's a mess, but I'm working on it.
was it the pixel base? No.
So,
if I just make it a fixed number of eval
right. What's that look like first?
We want to log this
All right.
now in practice
I can't do it this way Yeah.
How much extra eval could we allow, I
guess, is the question.
We're going to bias the crap out of it
if we're not careful.
Well, now this is an actual technical
question, right? It's like how long
should we let it run
But then what would the cut off be?
Oh, that's so annoying.
Okay, hang on. Let me pause this because
I can't I can't think clearly about
this. I'm just like,
so the problem here, right?
I can't figure out how I want to do the
eval cuto offs, right? How long do I
want to run evaluation after training?
This is an important question because at
the end of training, right, you have
episodes that are in progress. So the
start of those episodes have been
completed with a much worse policy,
meaning that many of those episodes can
get a much lower score than you actually
deserve under the current policy. Uh
there's no real way around this because
if you reset the environment and you
start collecting rollouts, the first
roll outs you collect are naturally
going to be the worst luck ones uh of
the policy because they're the ones that
finish first. Usually finishing first is
like a failure condition, though it
depends on the end. Depending on the
end, you can actually severely over or
underestimate
um you can severely over or
underestimate. Plus, resetting is janky
anyways.
So the next thing that you can do,
right, is you can just keep running
evals after training for a while until
the metrics stabilize. So that's kind of
a cool thing to do. But in that case,
then you need like a cut off point for
how many evals you're going to run or
how many samples you're going to collect
or something like that, right? Because
you don't want to have massively longer
evals uh than you have training. But at
the same time, there are some MS like
Pong for instance where you might run
training in 3 seconds, but you have to
run another couple seconds worth of
evals or otherwise you're just going to
get really bad metrics cuz the episodes
are very long.
So, I'm not sure what to do about that.
I'm not sure what to do about that.
The only thing I can think to do that's
going to be like nicely scaled is going
to be based on the number of agents,
right?
Like uh the number of episodes rather.
Okay, I guess we'll just keep going.
Really annoying.
Oh, I missed you. How was the end? M is
very cool for
thing is she
don't
semester exams are around in a week.
That's funny.
Well, I'm glad I'm more interesting than
that. I mean, this is just me like
pondering this pain in the ass. What's
the nicest way to refactor this?
Let me try to like Let's try this again.
This is shut [ __ ]
But um All right.
Yeah. You know, it's going to just be
gross
if I do it in two. It's going to be
gross.
mention
doing it in
We want these checkpoints as well, don't
we?
So the goal is
the goal is that we delete this,
right?
But this just doesn't work like straight
up
to do it this way.
It's just a convoluted piece of logic is
all it is.
It's just too much crap, right?
It's tough to do it in one loop. It's
also shitty if you do it in two.
Yeah, that's fun, man.
That's real fun.
Yes.
And what
How tough is open source exactly?
Cuz if a top tier like project like bra
struggles
breaks my heart when a maintainer has to
help, you have to monetize your [ __ ]
Like charity wear is a really shitty
business model. Just don't make charity
wear.
Like Puffer does not ask for donations.
We like we have contracts with companies
and we do custom stuff for people.
Open source is top tier. Yeah, but the
thing is that requires you to stop doing
your open source and go work on the top
labs [ __ ] which is depressing.
The reason I'm not at one of the top
labs is because I don't want to be at
one of the top labs. I want to be doing
my own top lab from the comfort of my
bedroom.
Do part-time open source. [ __ ] No.
At least the top couple of companies are
going to expect you to be working
uh quite a few hours.
It's actually way worse than that. Um,
you actually you just have to monetize
your stuff because otherwise then
what'll happen is the companies will use
the financial pressure to try to like
steal your work at a really [ __ ] price
as well.
Whole bunch of dumb stuff, man.
buffer closed
the core of it. Oh,
we could have individual applications,
right, that we work on that are like
specific closed war sims or something
that we sell.
But I generally think you don't want to
be
you don't want to be close forcing stuff
to the detriment of overall technical
progress in science.
It's actually pretty funny. Like a lot
of the big tech engineers straight up
can't contribute to open source because
they're too [ __ ] at it. Like they just
get all their PRs rejected and it's like
what the [ __ ] is this, you know?
Many of the well-known open- source
projects out there that are widely used
are just way higher quality than what
companies are cobbling together
internally
Is there anything I missed in this? I
think this is at least everything. Now,
this is a disastrous mess. Um,
can we do anything about this?
This one will get cleaner. This line
here
Yeah. And this is the fundamental
problem, right? is just
very often times
like in the long run, yes, just
optimizing money does get you technical
progress,
but it's often very inefficient.
It turns out that just by like actually
trying to advance tech, you advance tech
a hell of a lot faster. Who would have
thought?
I think I am going to just confuse the
crap out of people if I try to do this
in two loop uh in one loop. So I think I
have to do this in two loops.
Assume we're going to not have to deal
with rank.
Don't really add a lot of comments and
describing what you're doing. Good
etiquette. Do you see how much time I'm
spending making the thing like not crap?
Like, do you see how much effort is
going into me just trying to make this
thing not suck?
Like everything I'm doing right now is
not changing functionality except for
the very like the uh the sampling stuff.
I did at the start of the stream. Like
everything else I'm doing now is not
changing functionality.
It depends. There are times you need to
put comments, but like if you're having
to explain what your code is doing, your
code probably sucks with some very small
exceptions. Like if you have like um you
know if you're using like a specific
mathematical trick or you know something
like that then sure
tuned in after three to four months. I
see the same dedication. Yeah,
it just like code needs to not suck and
this is a very important section of the
code and it kind of sucks.
There's just it's just like a very weird
set of logic, you know? There's just too
many possible branches going on and it's
very difficult for me to get this clean
in my head.
Like it's like it looks like you can
just stick it all under one loop, but
then if you try to do that, it's not
quite
It drives me nuts that like I've just
been staring at this for hours.
But I said that this is what we were
going to get done today. I do actually
have to finish it today though. I can't
just be doing it forever. Let me use a
restroom real quick. I'll be back in a
minute.
I'm thinking maybe we just start
cleaning some unrelated stuff up inside
of here and then maybe that helps clean
up the control flow. We'll see.
Yeah, we'll see.
Don't have donations open
because um
this is not funded via charity man. So
it's
we do contracts with businesses.
We build uh high performance custom sims
for industry applications. We do
dedicated R&D, dedicated support for
puffer,
stuff like that.
So, we don't have like close source
tools or anything, right? It's not like
there's extra close source stuff you get
access to,
but that doesn't mean that stuff is not
monetized already.
And realistically, like no matter how
well I monetize um if I monetize users
like it's not going to come to a
fraction of what I'd be making doing
literally anything else. So, it's may as
well just keep it all free
and buffer Middle Eastern politics. I
think that one's MP complete.
How do you handle the thread pool for
GPU based MS? Is there a way to bypass
it? Yeah, so we don't have GPU based MS
at the moment. Um like you can just
basically replace the entire ve
interface though
with uh the GPU interface because it's
just a standard vector interface
anyways, right?
and match the interface with your GPU
ends
and it'll just work.
It's super slow. Well, puffer is
definitely not super slow.
Like what you should do is if you have a
GPU based end, you don't use the VE,
right? You just look at the VEC
interface. You match your GPU end
interface to that. Write a small wrapper
if you need vector wrapper, not single
end wrapper. And then you'll just get
native train speed with your GPU.
right. Hey, Jess. I basically just been
fighting this free factor all day.
Slow part is that the VE should happen
in the GPU, not the CPU.
The slow part is the Vic. Well, do you
have an existing GPU vector end, Carlos?
Because if you have an existing GPU back
end, you can just like replace puffers
back with that one line change
and then the data stays on the GPU.
Why are you refusing donations?
Because like it's meaningless, right?
There's not I'm not going to get any
number of donations to Puffer that are
going to make a difference compared to
us just charging businesses for um
custom Sims and the like.
We have a handful of active contracts at
the moment.
Oh jeez. Do not ask me to review Rust
code, please.
You're in the wrong spot for uh for
Rust, my friend.
Turbo Puffer. Yeah, I've seen them.
I think it's funny that the two like
fast libraries for different things are
just both puffer.
That's pretty good.
Puffer trainer because it's faster.
Yeah, Carlos.
Here's my own trainer. I didn't know I
could replace puffer. Yeah, just drop
in, dude. Like, look at it. The puffer.
It just has vec send ve receive. All
right. All it does sends batch of
actions gets back batch of observations.
Whatever your GPU interfaces, it's super
easy to just match to that. Puffer will
keep it on the GPU and there you go.
You're good.
What problems are you having? It's
literally just a veamp, right? Like
batch of observations, batch of actions.
talk about any businesses you've offered
custom sims. Uh, I can only talk about
one of the smaller ones at the moment
cuz there's only one of them where
they've like publicly done stuff.
Where is it? These guys. Um, they do
uh there is a simulator here for pricing
uh pricing data center compute. It's
like pricing compute allocations
that we're still working on for him.
The standard NV API hides that part
does it. It's just send and receive
right with the ops
fun for additional GPUs. Yeah, but Jess,
like I'm not going to get any reason
like any number of donations that make a
difference with that. Like we just do
one contract and then we can buy several
extra servers.
It's way more useful for me to just keep
it all open, have it as a learning
resource, have people submitting ends,
you know, hire people who are um good
from the open source community for
various contracts.
It's way better that way as well because
then I'm not selling anybody materials
or stuff like that, right?
I'm pretty happy with the way I've set
it up. Split.
The thing that does help, right, is just
like star the puffer, talk about it on
Twitter, you know, submit cool MS, stuff
like that helps.
gets her just gets our stuff out there.
We do get company contracts via DMs on X
every so often.
Actual Python, it's just the rapper, my
guy. It's like 500 lines. It's going to
be less than 500 lines total of um
Python just for the runner.
Yeah, I am much happier when I'm writing
C.
Man, I've literally spent eight hours so
far today staring at a total of a 100
lines of Python. I hate this language.
Not to mention that you ship a Python
package and then two years later nobody
can install it
because the whole ecosystem sucks.
Chief Puffer sales officer. I think
Chief uh the uh Chief Procelite as it is
for Puffer has got to be bet. He's done
so much promo.
I guess we can do it this way.
Pip version 50. I swear PIP needs to
just get [ __ ] Like god, that's shitty
thing.
UV doesn't even solve everything either
because the standards are independent
and they keep updating the [ __ ]
standards for no reason.
No, that was actually a pretty new um he
hadn't like written any code before he
started on stuff and he's written a
couple of pretty nice environments.
Nice.
Oh, C is just great. You run C code from
12 years ago and it just [ __ ] works
and it's fast. Like a thousand times
faster.
You're modern garbage.
I swear programming peaked in the 70s.
Okay, maybe the 90s, but like [ __ ] All
of modern software engineering is just
people finding incredibly clever ways to
do things worse.
I was honestly starting to think about
like, you know, going more into running
the company and doing science and
programming less and like stopping doing
IC because of how [ __ ] all of this stuff
was. And then I realized, wait,
actually, that's not even what
programming is. We've just all been lied
to. So, thankfully, I kept going long
enough to realize it.
Like software the way that it's done
according to best practices nowadays is
just like a depressing, draining, awful
job. I don't recommend it to anybody.
How many contributors work in big labs?
I know a couple do. I don't know how I
have no idea how many total
And the problem is most of the
frameworks simply should not exist.
They're just bad.
I mean the best way to do that in is
just code review.
I review PRs. I'm not going to teach
like a literally I've never programmed
before course. That's not what this is
about.
I have some general tips for new people,
but
like this is not beginner work.
This is push cutting edge of research
forward
Yeah, I've still ended up with more code
than I started with, which pisses me off
so much.
Like programming is hard. Programming is
very poorly taught.
I'm not saying you're an idiot for
writing bad code. Like you're probably
taught to write very bad code by your
idiot teacher,
but I am going to point out everything
that's wrong. And then you're going to
see how to do it better. And then you're
going to learn [ __ ]
Okay, this line is bothering the crap
out of me, but this is going to get
moved.
Other than this line
What's three for? Yeah, that's a decent
enough answer.
I mean, it's interactive intelligence is
a better name for it. Learning through
interaction.
Uh, I really do not like Anthropic in
any way, but yeah, the uh DoD managed to
be even shittier. So,
congrats
Let me try one last time to do it the
other way.
Okay, if I can figure out how to cobble
together
this
and then this, I think
I'd be a little skeptical of that
threat. I' like you'd need some pretty
good evidence.
I think it's more likely that the models
just kind of suck.
All the dependencies come with it. Yeah,
Weston. Um, I mean, you have to have
CUDA on the host, right? Like the
machine that you're the container on has
to have CUDA installed and it has to
match. Um, that's it.
puff if you're trying to do puffer 4
that's not set up correctly yet out of
the box for three it should work
paste in Discord you'll get help I'm
trying to refactor this crap right now
and it's driving me nuts I've been live
eight and a half hours
It means Luis Suare is the soccer
player.
The only thing this doesn't do is update
the old logs, right?
Uh yeah, you should just tap that thing
off most likely.
laptop screen is hardwired to the iGPU.
That's insane.
Why the [ __ ] does it have a a discrete
GPU then? That's [ __ ]
Wait. Model path.
Wait. Join
checkpoint. Dur. How'd this get [ __ ]
up again?
Dude,
the [ __ ] autocomplete just screwed me
again.
this.
Do you follow any sport?
No, I run and I lift myself.
Just trying to refactor this jazz. It's
annoying cuz Python has all this stuff
you can do to make stuff super compact.
It's like it has to be super compact.
Annoying
I wanted less [ __ ] Jess, I don't
know what to tell you.
And then what?
And all we need is
Why I changed the name Puffer Live? I
don't know how the [ __ ] I describe what
I do. Here, have a puffer. It's a fun
mascot. It puffs up.
We do all sorts of fancy infrastructure.
Now puffer.
Enjoy.
Yeah, this is very irritating. I think
it's still not quite there yet.
buffers are pretty good.
You know, they like pop up and stuff.
If I can get this logs updated
correctly, this will work.
So,
now. See, it's still not good.
Don't want to add this.
Let me see if this is at least correct.
Roll out
train.
It's so much easier.
Hang on. I just realized I can maybe
simplify.
All right, I'm going to use the restroom
real quick. We're going to finish this
and I'm going to get dinner. I'll be
right back.
see
and then we'll just
I think we got it, guys.
[ __ ] hell. This is like not an easy
refactor.
That got brain damage.
Jesus.
Roll outs.
Do training checkpoints every checkpoint
interals
or at the end of training.
Do the dashboard every 6 seconds, but
also at the end of
training
only the end after training otherwise
the full logs update flat logs
the dashboard
This would actually be pretty useful to
see
This is so close to being like not total
[ __ ]
This one works. The only thing that this
breaks our constellation logs.
Wait, our constellation logs are fine
here.
So all we need is the flat locks at the
end, right?
oper
less than equal
All right, I'm going to just go stick
this somewhere.
Let's just go stick this at the bottom
of the file for now.
this with a couple comments more good. I
think.
Let me go over this manually.
Here's the target key.
We go through
epochs. We do roll outs. We do training.
Here's checkpointing.
These are messed up. The bottom's messed
up.
I'm getting hungry. It's been a lot of
work.
I love how it just like [ __ ] ces
stuff and then lies to you. That's my
favorite.
We're just going to delete all the
Python, man. I swear it's such a [ __ ]
language.
Rotten all the dependencies.
Something you usually get. No, that's
that can just happen. You can just get
warnings now because um it's just
dependency rot.
We're eventually just going to delete
all the Python and just have C in CUDA.
I think
it's not rendering as probably something
else.
your drivers maybe
libg or whatever
you might have to install um lib mesa or
whatever
You want the laws
the end of training.
I just have to There's like a few lines
change, man. We're good.
It's also just not
right. How do we have it be the thing
that we want?
Jeez, we've been live almost 10 hours
already.
I think this is good.
All right, like this is
quite shorter. What are we doing right
now? We're still refactoring our
training code. Um, mostly now just going
through and checking it and going to be
testing it soon.
I need to add a couple very small things
which Claude will do. I did all this by
hand.
very stupid this thing. We'll have to
make this less redundant after.
Anytime you ask us to do anything, it'll
do it the dumbest way possible.
Downside.
I am tired though and I need this to at
least have an implementation.
We'll clean up Cuda later. I was hoping
we could clean Cuda today, but like
Previously worked in data science in
vanilla MLM solos. What are you
currently working on? I am currently
refactoring our main training
implementation
um with a little bit of new logging
logic and trying to clean up the way
that we evaluate
our models at the end of training.
It's mostly what I'm doing at the
moment. Okay, so this is ending early.
That's not good.
10 hours. Yeah, I've been live 10 hours.
What of it?
Another day in the life, my guy.
I'm probably going to work a little bit
either off stream or on stream after
dinner as well.
I actually much prefer it this way where
I just have some very long days and then
there's some days where I just like man,
learning is not going to be some [ __ ]
prompts.
We'll leave it like this for now. It's
I can't be using this thing. Look, every
single time it just makes a mess.
Implementation of masking. Mask the
gradient of I don't know what he
suggested.
Um,
oh man, I haven't messed with masking in
so long.
You're supposed to mask the entire
forward pass of it, which would then
mask the gradient.
Like because the autograd, if you mask
the forward, there's no backward.
Backwards pulls forwards. Not exactly.
There's a computer graph though.
The puffer evels very fast. That's
funny.
That's kind of funny it does it that
way. Yeah.
We actually do need to make a
deterministic though. That's a slight
problem.
I kind of like that even though that's a
bug.
That will end up being less code. I have
to refactor it. Add some stupid code in
the C.
This is shorter than before.
Let me go double check to find
something.
All right, I gotta go for dinner, guys.
Um, I might stream after, I might not.
I'm probably going to do a couple hours
of work either way on this. We shall
see.
Uh, for everybody who's been watching,
thank you all for tuning in. I stream
pretty much all the dev through this
project. It's all open source. If you
want to help me out for absolutely free,
start the project on GitHub. It's
puffer.ai. Here's the GitHub. Really
helps us out a lot. Uh, you can join the
discord to get involved with dev or you
can follow me at I got a nice new handle
JS now. It's also where all my articles
are, all the educational stuff. It's all
free. Um, yeah, I stream dev on fast and
sane RL every day. Pretty much every
day. Been slacking a little lately, but
I've been make up for with the long
streams.